AMV which stands for anime music video
is a music video made using anime clips
am I going too fast tell me if I'm going
too fast aim these have been a staple of
the anime fandom for pretty much as long
as I can remember since we first realize
they can take their favorite songs and
oh my god you put anime clips over it
it's been a symbol of anime fan
expression and passion and has been a
massive part of my anime fandom even if
I've never properly gotten into the
scene I have so many fond memories just
wasting afternoons watching a MV so some
of my favorite anime so today I thought
I'd start my own appreciation thread on
the history and influence AMD's have had
on a humble fandom and you know
reminisce on some of the videos I got me
through when I was just a budding little
weed sprouts the origins of AMD's date
back to the 1980s where people would
literally have to hook up to VCRs
together and record from one type to
another which is a process I don't even
want to fathom and I know you're
thinking oh what the hell's a VCR
grandpa
either way the rise of AMD's would truly
come with the digital era when any
average bum could easily obtain anime
clips and digital editing software
legally allowing pretty much anyone with
a working computer to make an A MV this
was paired with easy ways to share them
online on sites like anime music video
org and popular up-and-coming video
sharing sites like dailymotion of course
I'm talking about or would you tuber
back then YouTube's video quality was so
bad it was actually frowned upon to
upload a MVS on there so from purely
exposure on youtube uploads most people
understood a and B so V these shoddily
and its advices to the sound of let the
bodies hit the floor extra cancer points
went to how many of the Four Horsemen of
the Amb pocalypse were present you had
video rendered by a potato subtitles
still included the DivX logo showing up
every few seconds and of course the king
himself unregistered hypercam to mom get
the camera I made my first day in B and
it looks amazing
of course hang around the community
enough and sure enough you would have
stumbled upon one or two videos that
would have opened your eyes to the
possibilities a MVS could have had and
for me that video was euphoria No
not not not that not that euphoria just
mmm just no euphoria by koopa skevur was
the video that introduced me to the
potential of a mb/s
it wasn't just a collection of fights
poorly time to some teen angst new metal
rock songs there was genuine thought and
how the visuals matched the songs it had
really impressive effects for the time
and it got me interested in an anime I
have never even heard of before back
when I looked at the title and thought
ah what the hell is of rahxephon this
opens the door for me to search for
other things am bees could achieve you
add tainted donuts which acted are one
of my purest teenage fan fiction
fantasies of having spike Spiegel face
off against Vash the Stampede whisper of
the beast which was one of the only good
in the ruto AMD's that came out at the
time and then came skittles candy pop
there were two am bees that defines my
early anime fandom and this was one of
them when I first saw they said
absolutely blew my mind with visual
effects that were way ahead of its time
I would play this over and over until I
could recite all the lyrics my heart I'm
just listening to these lyrics I'm just
realizing what the [ __ ] was I singing to
put into perspective how all this AMV is
I was just starting [ __ ] Windows
Movie Maker image slideshow anime
reviews there is an old re-upload of
this on YouTube that says click 480p for
high quality clean and crisp 480p this
is when I remember the a MVC and really
hitting its stride and with it came a
trend I have to talk about and that is
the impact of a certain bands by the
name of Linkin Park and is unintentional
pairing with pretty much every anime but
in particular one that is better known
by the name of Sasuke's best friend I am
not exaggerating when I say there was a
time that if he typed in a MV on YouTube
9 out of 10 videos would have been
paired with a Linkin Park song probably
featuring Naruto and probably featuring
his one best friend
the [ __ ] swing there is no official
answer to why this was but honestly I
don't think it's any more complicated
than the works of chester bennington &
co rest in peace god bless your soul
resonating with a generation of young
anime fans i just wanted to express
their passion in some way to some of
their favorite anime as anime fans we
were all probably socially awkward teens
who didn't quite fit in that school so
obviously this anger and angst would
resonate with us and their musics beat
and tempo just made it a natural fit for
every bloody anime fight scene in
existence so it was an easy pairing we
were dealing with problems that nobody
else got like Becky still doesn't know I
exist and mom told me to mow the lawn
again i miss green gave me detention
again because i didn't put my hand up
and asking to go to the toilet the [ __ ]
but you know what it's okay because this
song gets me chester gets me and you get
me to naruto vs sasuke bull fights HD
60fps from there on am bees continue to
evolve and improve effects got more
intricate projects got more ambitious
and every so often you get a mega hit
that would spread amongst the entire
community and these were the ones i
ended up seeing most rama was the first
AMD editor who are actually got familiar
with my name for their crisp flow and
perfect scene selection that didn't need
overly complicated effects to stand out
like a well-oiled anime music machine
then he had the craze of bubble gum high
impact high energy amv sync to catchy
pop songs with enough saturated colors
to blind the [ __ ] unicorn comedy a
MVS with cleverly edited original
concepts story MVS where the editor
completely recontextualized the footage
to make their own original story then
you had the ones that started a trend
the anime ography series bike will
really encapsulating the new seasonal
anime trend showcasing all the animes in
a year in just [ __ ] match cuts did I
mention my kinks is videos with match
cuts in them and this video series is
just like foreplay for my eyes god
dammit into the labyrinth which took
this frame blending effect and proved
that you can make anime look even better
than anime I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if this video alone started
the whole watching anime in 60fps crazy
cuz i did not know i wanted to watch
anime at 60fps until I saw this a MV and
seeing how this effects has been used in
modern day MVS just like oh it's like if
smooth buttery jazz could caress
your eyes and so so many more that I
won't be able to name or might have
missed because it wasn't uncommon for an
amv back then to get several millions of
views and the start of the decades
AMD's dominated the anime fandom AMD's
were the bee's knees they were the cat's
meow
they were the dogs bullets there were
the cows pancreas I don't know I'm just
[ __ ] naming body parts at this point
last they Envy I remember getting super
super popular was an amazement everyone
was either watching it or doing reaction
videos to it and I remember thinking
cool concept an awesome execution aside
someone must really hate themselves to
consciously do this much masking I mean
are you okay dude is life treating you
okay who who hurt you no no no no
seriously who who hurts you just show me
on the doll what they did to you but
there is another subset of am visa want
to mention those that are basically a
collection of shorter anime theme skits
time to some music or a Vox Pop I
mentioned before that there were two
a.m. V's that defines my early fandom
and the second one was a MV hell 3 the a
MV hell series was just a collection of
short anime skits strung together but
what made a MV hell 3 specials that they
caught in a movie because it was just an
hour long of skits back-to-back now you
may be wondering why would anyone want
to watch over an hour of stupid anime
skits don't you have something better to
do with your time and to that I say why
does anyone tell themselves they're just
gonna watch a bit of this 20 minute vine
compilation' and then I'll go back to
doing whatever I was doing before my
2007 compilations in this is not how I
plans my day looking back now a lot of
these skits were just basic level let's
put a funny song then fine anomie clips
that match the lyrics but in a time when
meme culture was just starting for my
teenage brain who has yet acclimated to
internet humor this was the funniest
[ __ ] ever well you mean there's a clip
of an anime character spinning around to
the theme of you spin me round' by dead
or alive these kinds of videos have
gotten a resurgence recently in the form
of anime vines and cracks and I think
there's one video we can thank for that
and that is anime 404 by Barker oh boy
buckaroo pie is one of the few editors
that have actually managed to make a
huge name for themselves outside of just
the amv community where everything they
make made
was a viral hits his first hit a piece
of toast got pretty big with an anime
404 came along and completely blew that
out of the water and I seem to remember
after this or a wave of new compilations
of similar shorts edited anime skits in
the form of vines and cracks and this
leads me to the state of AM vs today
because while it is still alive and
active it's just not the same as it used
to be
AMV used to be right up there some of
the most viral videos you can have in
the anime community the videos everyone
would be aware of even if you didn't
know who made it but now that's not
really the case I'm sure you can even
find some newer fans who don't even know
what an a MV is I think the reasoning
for this is similar to the reason of the
decline of animations on YouTube years
ago a.m. these take a shitload of effort
for a short amount of content which
doesn't suit modern YouTube and media
consumption while also having to fight
against copyrights not only that but the
anime community is just far bigger than
it used to be a viral hits back then is
just a standard video today so nowadays
instead of being an integral part of the
anime fandom aim fees kind of just stay
in the amv community from talking to
people in the community it's alive but
just very split
directed by M night Shyamalan pretty
good movie actually you have smaller
groups of people posting on all sorts of
different platforms for example a lot of
people are posting smaller edits on
Instagram but I mean who the [ __ ] uses
Instagram am i right but without
anything unifying the scene to the rest
of the outside anime community it just
doesn't have the same notoriety used to
envy competitions are still big in
conventions but in the grand scheme of
things they are far from the main
attraction so what point am i trying to
make with this video gig or why are you
wasting time talking about stupid Linkin
Park anime videos when you can be
talking about real topics to me am v's
are another way for anime fans to
express and share their passion for this
medium and it's a passion that I felt
when I was just starting to be an anime
fan and had no friends I could share
this passion with so I wanted to make
this video partially to say thank you as
a fellow content creator for making
these pieces of work that have been a
crucial part of my fandom for as long as
I can remember and partially to give me
an excuse to show off some of my
favorite a MVS that have
by me with my absolute favorites being
steel fenders from the late Amica rest
in peace and pencil-head by quacker the
former being a reimagined piece of the
phase zero universe so well edited the
first time I watched it I was like what
the [ __ ] did I miss a phase euro VA or
something wait a minute is that saber of
the Cape I want saber with a cape give
me saber with a cape and the latter
shattered all my preconceived notions of
what an a MV could be I mean I would
even has it to call this an A MV because
it is just a piece of [ __ ] are that
still blows my mind to this day if you
want to watch any a MVS after this watch
these two but if you want to lose a
whole afternoon watching a MV then I'll
also link a playlist of some my favorite
AM V's in the description along with an
A and B that I made yes I too did also
partake in the making of nay MV back in
the day just because I appreciate the
work that goes into them and for any
young budding amv makers who are look at
something like this and it's inspired to
do something similar well it's pretty
easy really all you need to do is some
simple masking which I can teach you
right now so what you need to do is you
need to find your clip and once you do
then we're just gonna cut this out frame
by frame so you need to use the pen tool
and you just start putting down points
and then you just keep doing it until
you cut it out and then you go to the
next frame and then you just do the same
thing again
all right I'm done let's see what my
masterpiece looks like
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to
Nicolas Tatum sundown fun matey malabon
are sisters one zero zero eight six LF
all and everyone else on patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible how do we
don't mind me showing my face a bit more
on this video a life of food an anime
one I was trying to experiment a bit
with new types of videos I have a lot of
fun experimenting with new stuff here
and there but as usual don't expect it
to be the norm for anyone else who
doesn't know I will also be attending
crunchyroll Expo at the end of this
month our that's just gonna go through
the start of September so if you're
going I will see you there anyway that's
it for me today no further updates so
until my next video I've been Gigot and
I will see you all next time